the European Union is a time to say
goodbye it's been a rough few years for
the EU especially for its legitimacy and
even supporters get why yeah they're not
very tangible benefits on their everyday
life much more scale but with that said
that's good come on yeah not bad pretty
daunting astronaut hey guys it's Sunnah
and this Sunday at aj+ we're gonna
explore the question of why there is so
much drama over the European Union and
why your skepticism
aka skepticism about the existence of
the EU is on the rise
let's start with your European Union
basics today the EU has 28 member states
and that's still including the UK for
now about five other countries are
waiting to join the club and what is
being a member of the Union get you well
you get to be a part of the world's
largest trading bloc the European single
market that means trade without
restrictions among all countries that
are within the EU
it also means having the benefits of a
powerful unified front when it comes to
negotiating trade deals with countries
outside of the EU in fact within the EU
all movement of goods services and
people is unrestricted and that's
something that Europeans are feel very
strongly about the most obvious benefit
of being a European Union citizen is
that we can travel and work wherever we
want in the Union file is a montage
barge the most is an alternative which
each we couldn't meet on potala on
through the voyage at 4 o'clock you just
Alex more
today yeah credit relations antennas you
know but not what is the date motive in
your own horse about two different cell
you on the team so with all this
collaboration happening across the
economy across trade how does it
actually work who decides what happens
at how well there are seven EU
institutions which include an executive
branch two legislative branches a
judicial branch and a central bank each
member country directly elects and sends
representatives to the European
Parliament and there are a total of 751
MEP from across Europe by the way
remember Nigel Faraj the face of brexit
the EU failing the EU is dying I hope
we've knocked the first brick out of the
wall he's a member of European
Parliament so why all this skepticism
about something that sounds kind of
solid professor John Gillingham thinks
it's been flawed from the get-go
the basic reason for it is the
unrepresentative character of european
institutions which don't provide a
proper mechanism for public feedback the
European Union is not a democracy or
anything like it the European Union
exists in a kind of a political
diplomatic never-never-land now usually
when we hear about your skepticism we
hear about the xenophobic anti-immigrant
rhetoric that is at the heart of several
euro skeptic political parties and
movements but what are some other
criticisms of the EU well take a euro
currency for example it was introduced
in 2002 and it's used across 19
countries and for a while there it
seemed like it was working but then the
global financial crisis spread to Europe
in late 2009 five countries that use the
currency at Greece Portugal Ireland
Spain and Cyprus were unable to pay
their government debt and had to be
bailed out and for a while there there
was even talk of Greece abandoning the
currency altogether and experts argued
that this was due to a lack of economic
integration now what does that mean well
it's like this you have one currency for
19 different countries meaning one
currency for 19 different economies some
of those economies are strong like
Germany's and others are like Greece's
yeah deeply rich
yippy Morris better company our
departure
sequelae pH da da - cool cool Italy PA
the people not all economies are gonna
respond to difficult or even good times
in the same way in the aftermath of the
financial crisis EU politicians forced
countries like Greece to make deep
budget cuts to make them more
competitive that led to big austerity
measures and Greek citizens took the
streets but some argue that isn't enough
and that in order for the euro to
succeed their economies have to look
more alike that means a more centralized
approach which brings us to the next
critique of the EU the argument that too
much power has been taken away from
national governments and given to EU
institutions critics argued that the EU
is calling the shots more than
individual governments take the European
Parliament for example over the years in
an effort to make the EU more democratic
and add to its legitimacy more power has
been given to the European Parliament
today nearly everything the EU does
requires approval from Parliament and
since the EU is involved in as much as
half of all legislation in Europe some
say that makes the European Parliament
more powerful than most national
legislatures and at the same time if
fewer people are interested in EU
parliamentary elections voter turnout
has spawned consistently since 1979
that combination of more power and less
voter participation makes some people
uncomfortable to solve our monsters
recap book we talked to the national in
your bank account Antonova sasaki cozily
we prevent the Rojas post the question
of EU expansion or enlargement as it's
awkwardly called has been hotly debated
since its inception part of the argument
against adding new countries goes back
to the issue of economic integration
because the euro is already struggling
with 19 different economies while adding
more even helped but the other part of
the argument has to do with the free
movement of people within the EU friends
barely approved the Maastricht Treaty in
1992 and they failed to ratify the
European Constitution in 2005 and a big
part of the concern in both cases
focused on immigration and Asylum now
there's a possibility that majority
Muslim Turks
might join the EU and add to that the
refugee crisis and bam anti-immigrant
sentiments are easily stoked but
professor Gillingham says that in the
majority of countries it's not hatred or
xenophobia but fear of losing jobs or
welfare Europeans quitter of the
so-called political right the so-called
political that are profoundly
conservative they're satisfied with
their way of life the benefits of the
welfare state and they don't want them
to erode disappear or be challenged
that's that xenophobia has been a huge
part of many euro skeptic movements and
groups which gives your skepticism in
and of itself a bad name so where does
the EU go from here Gillingham is an
optimistic there's really no hope at all
that the European Union will acquire new
powers that will strengthen it the road
would might lead to a genuine Federal
Union along the lines of the United
States nevertheless there's a huge push
for reform from both Pro and anti EU
groups the pro EU French President
Emmanuel macron acknowledged the
dysfunction of the EU and ran on a
platform of reform he's suggested
creating a euro zone common budget to
invest in growth across the ball and the
EU itself recognizes that it has little
choice left but to change the European
Commission President jean-claude Juncker
presented a report that looks at how
Europe will change over the next decade
and outlines different paths for the EU
it offers five scenarios ranging from
expanding and centralizing power in EU
institutions to refocusing efforts
around the single market the European
Commission will decide on a vision for
the future of the bloc and it will be
put to a vote at the next European
parliamentary election in 2019 in other
words it will be up to EU citizens
themselves to decide and what they
decide will determine the future of all
Europeans so the future of the European
Union is really kind of up in the air
and I personally am a little worried
about what will happen to Eurovision
what do you guys think let us know in
the comments and don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and come back next
Sunday where we're gonna have another
awesome video I promise